Do you have any thoughts on what [inaudible] disciplines someone can use to
improve their decision making skills as a leader?
Not only in keeping clarity of thought during high pressured situations and
environments,
but also in making the correct decisions when it is vital.
Okay,
so we've talked about this last week.
You have to learn to detach and how do you learn to detach?
You learned at hatch by putting yourself in stressful situations and then
observing how you react.
So good stress,
stressful situations to put yourself in.
Well,
what makes you stressed?
One thing that will make everyone stressed,
especially when they first start,
is start with Jujitsu.
That's gonna,
that's gonna put you in stressful environments.
Look at sports.
What are you going to do?
You know,
put yourself in stressful positions in sports.
What else makes you stress?
Public speaking,
public speaking makes some people really stressed out and start doing it more.
What about competition?
Shooting where you've got to or hunting where you've got to do something in a
stressful environment or archer,
you know,
I started started archery recently.
You did?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
And so that's one of those things where you've got to learn to detach.
You gotta learn to pay attention to things that are going on.
If you're all caught up in the moment,
then you're going to miss it.
So that's number one.
If you want to learn to deal with stress,
put yourself in stressful situations that are under some kind of control.
You know,
even something like a paint ball,
you know,
we do gigs at echelon front where we put people through what we call FTX is
where you go out and you're going to fire.
We usually use airsoft because it's a little bit more,
it's a little easier to work with.
But actually what we started using now is we've got these high end laser tag
guns and so that's,
that's what we use.
And they are super effective.
They're there,
they're awesome.
They're awesome training tools.
LikeW if we would've had them,
if we would've,
if they would've existed when I was in the seal teams,
I would have used them then because they're that good.
So we use those and we put people in stressful situations.
Go hit this target.
There's bad guys,
you know people are going to get shot.
There's people yelling.
Put yourself in stress,
stressful situations and learn to detach.
Put yourself in stressful situations with the purpose of learning to detach and
stepping back mentally to figure out what's going on.
Okay,
that's first part.
Next part is how do we make good decisions?
Well,
number one,
making correct decisions.
You've got to study,
you got to know and understand.
You've got to know the background,
you've got to know the historical outcomes of equivalent type decisions that
have happened in the past,
similar situations.
And if you know the history and you know the background,
then you can use those to assess the current situation you're in.
And then once you assess the decisions that you can make,
assess the possible actions that you can take and then assess the outcomes that
those decisions will have.
Those actions will have.
And when you're doing that,
you also have to assess the possibilities of inaction.
So a lot of times people forget that one,
they don't know.
They don't know if they should do a or B.
What they forget is there's also,
what if I don't do either?
What's going to happen?
Sometimes not doing either as good,
most that were a lot of times not doing either is bad.
So you've got a or B,
what should you do?
Maybe sometimes you've got to pick a or B.
Sometimes occasionally it's better not to do anything and you wait and let the
situation developed a little bit more.
What?
So the point of this is whatever you can know beforehand,
you know,
you learn,
you study,
you understand,
you know the standard operating procedures,
you know what various variations have been made on the standard operating
procedures and that's how you go forward and you execute.
Now the thing that you have to remember is that you can't know everything
beforehand,
which is why it goes back to study and practice detaching and making decisions.
So,
so now let me dig into detaching a little bit.
Let's actually break that down.
Maybe some mechanical steps that you can use.
Number one,
step back,
like literally physically take a step back from the situation that you're in and
move your head and look around.
So when we used to shoot,
they would teach us to scan like you would have to physically move your head.
And what that is is a mental reminder that you need to look around and assess
what's happening.
So once you've taken a step off the line,
whether that's taken a step back from the table,
when you're in a meeting,
if you're a,
if you're a firefighter and there's a fire happening,
take a step back so you can see the bigger picture.
If you're in a cop and and there's a shootout happening,
where can you go to step back,
get some cover and look around and see what's actually happening.
If you're in a,
if you're in a conversation with someone,
stop talking.
If there's an argument going on,
stop talking,
take a step back and actually listened to all the other elements that are
shouting and yelling at each other.
If there's a decision that means to needs to be made,
I don't on a planning situation,
step back from the plan.
Don't just take a step back from it,
look at it more broadly.
So that's step number one is to step back.
Number two,
then you're gonna come up with,
hey,
what are the possible decisions that I can make?
I could go this way.
I A,
I could do any one of these things.
Keep an open mind.
This is the problem some people have is they come up with two decisions,
three decisions and they don't think about anything else,
so you kind of have to like repeatedly detach.
You kind of have to stay detached.
That's why it's good you throw out an idea,
like if we're planning for something and I come up with three ideas,
I say,
echo,
what do you think of these?
I give them to you.
Then I stepped back again.
I keep my mind open,
so that's why the more you can get your subordinates to plan,
the better off you're going to be.
The more you can get the people below you in the chain of command to come up
with an idea or come up with the ideas,
the better off you're going to be because you're not embroiled in it.
You're,
you're defacto detached because you're letting them run with it.
Then,
okay,
once you look at your decisions and you've got to look at what the possible
outcomes are,
what are the possible things that can happen?
Is this could,
how bad could this go?
Risk versus reward.
You got to weigh those things out and you got to do it fairly quickly and again,
you've got to,
you've got to figure out what's the result or possible outcome for inaction,
and then you just weigh out these various options that you've created and you
figure which one,
which outcome has the most,
which one makes the most sense?
That's that's what's good,
and like I said,
inaction is some people like any action is better than no action,
not always true,
not always true.
Sometimes you can learn more by letting things develop and letting things reveal
what the status is.
So that does make sense.
And sometimes you do hold off.
If if you,
if you can see that a problem is getting worse though,
we'll then we've got to do something.
Then generally,
okay,
let's make some kind of a decision very quickly.
Now,
one of the most important things to remember,
and there's a little dichotomy to this,
is that you don't always have to make giant decisions.
You don't always have to make the,
all the,
the,
the all powerful decision of might,
you know,
it's like,
do we go or do we not go?
You don't always have to say,
we go.
Sometimes you can go,
well,
let's push a little further.
Let's,
let's move.
Let's move a little bit further before we make that decision.
Or,
Hey,
let's stay where we are and see if it develops or let's back up a little bit and
keep watching.
So instead of we go,
or we don't go,
there's actually a bunch of different decisions that you can make besides,
we can go or don't go.
There's a building,
there's a bad guy in it.
Let's go.
Or let's not go.
No,
actually,
let's put eyes on the target for a little while.
Let's,
let's call and see if there's any other intelligence.
Let's put an aircraft over half.
There's all kinds of decisions that you can make.
Let's push a little bit closer.
Let's stage,
let's monitor.
So there's all kinds of decisions that you can make that allow the,
the situation to develop further and maybe reveal the proper decision to you in
the long run.
So my,
my fear of saying that is that people be get paralyzed.
What does it analyze?
The parallel and parallel analysis paralysis.
That's my fear about saying that because the dichotomy is you can sit around and
analyze and figure out and look at something for over,
for forever while the situation changes and now you lose.
So yes,
you don't have to make giant decisions,
but at the same time you gotta be decisive.
There's a dichotomy.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
Leadership is not easy.
Wrote a whole book about it.
Dichotomy.
Leadership.
Why?
Cause that's what happens.
So there you go.
That's my assessment of how you can improve your decision making skills.
Experience goes a long way.
Yes.
Yeah.
That's when one of those,
just kind of,
when you were talking about the,
the results versus the,
the,
the method,
right?
Decision making sometimes like the result,
actually both method end results kind of the value isn't even in the results.
It's like you haven't getting that experience going through it,
you know,
it'll improve your decision making.
Sure,
sure.
Yeah.
Thanks Shane.
Anytime you can be in a situation where you're making decisions and getting
experience out at,
you're going to get better at it.
Yeah.
Kind of the value and role playing that is a value.
That's why we do a lot of role playing in echelon for like a little thing and
people might think like,
oh that,
how does that work?
Come and get it,
get it.
I watch people all the time.
It totally improve as leaders because put them through a role play scenario as a
leader where they're going up against a combative subordinate or a subordinate
that's lazy or I subordinates angry or a subordinate that that wants to leave.
Like you put,
you put a person role playing in those situations over and over again and they
get so much better.
Three iterations,
three iterations and people are exponentially better at handling situations.
Yeah.
Cause it's like some,
I mean most of the time anyway,
it's just a matter of them like never seen it before.
And then in the during game time it's kind of like you've got to make the
decision super fast so you can't,
and analysts from the role playing situation,
you can analyze,
you can do whatever and then t and then learn it.
I actually should have brought that up.
That's a great point.
Is another way that you can get better at making decisions by role play for
sure.
Give yourself the options.
Put,
put your,
set yourself up a pressure situation and have people role play it out with you
of what you're gonna do it.
So it's kind of like,
like mock that.
That's basically what it is.
It is mock experience.
That's basically what seal training,
well not the basic seal training,
but the seal training that I run,
that's basically what it was.
We're going to have people act like bad guys and you're going to make decisions
all day long.
That's a roleplay.
Yeah.
Get some,
yeah,
she,
I remember and again going back to like just seeing it once,
right.
They've seen at one time is is way bigger difference than then.
I mean compared with never seeing it all versus seen at once.
The difference between that is way bigger than seeing it like twice versus once
you know,
if you see the ones it's Kinda like,
okay,
now know.
Yeah,
this,
yeah.
It's like night and day.
It's night and day.
The difference between knowledge and like,
no,
no.
Knowledge is crazy.
Yeah.
And we see that over and over and over again.
Like an Indiana Jones and the last crusade.
You ever seen that one?
I'm pretty sure.
Wait,
how old is that one?
I saw the all like that series when we shot on Connor was a kid.
I think I see.
So at the end and go through things right?
That they are like these booby traps.
Right?
Do you get the holy grail?
That's what they're doing.
Oh,
then I've seen this one cause everyone,
the guy's face melts,
right?
No,
that's right.
It's the last cycle when they open the Ark.
Oh you gotta shut your eyes.
Yeah.
That's old school anyway.
No,
this one,
they have to go through these like these tests or whatever.
They're there booby traps to get to the holy grail and one of them was you have
to kneel.
Only the penitent man will pass.
That's what it says in the grill diary,
which is Indiana Jones Dad's diary that took all the notes in.
And so he's like all you got interpret that.
Right.
So they had all these people,
there were bad days there too.
So they just send to someone in there and then the guide go in and is a head
gets chopped off.
So you go in there,
you know,
hey that blade is going to come chop off my head cause I seen that one guy get
his head chopped off.
I'm just gonna duck just one time.
That's all I got to know that blade's gonna come out duck.
Good point.
Thanks Cindy.
Grand.
Granted there was more booby traps and you kind of got to refer to the grill
diary for the answers.
It's subject to interpretation by the way,
but same deal.
You see the point though,
right?
If you walk through a hall,
I get it.
Yeah.
You see that guy get his head chopped off,
you know?
Okay.
I better duck now.
Your best doc.
Yeah.
Yup.
I get it.
Thank you.
One time.